- Why is it certain businesses
can hover above their competition?
I mean, is Starbucks really
serving the best cup of coffee?
I mean, to want, and to be ambitious,
and to want to be
successful is not enough.
Very often the thing
that actors tend to do,
is I think they tend to
focus on the wrong thing.
And every time I take on something,
the only thing that interests
me is what scares me.
- He's an American actor,
film director, producer,
comedian, and singer.
He began his career as a
stage actor in the 1980s.
Since 2013, he's played Frank Underwood
on the Netflix series House of Cards,
for which he's won numerous awards.
He's Kevin Spacey,
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number eight is my personal favorite.
And make sure to stick around
all the way til the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Kevin is talking,
if he says something that
really is meaningful to you,
make sure to write it down
in the comments below,
and put quotes around it so
others can be inspired as well.
(jet engine)
- Well we all are in the
business of storytelling.
I mean it's not just
exclusive for people like me
who are in the entertainment business.
I think that, no matter
what business you're in,
no matter what you're selling or doing.
Why is it certain businesses can hover
above their competition?
I mean is Starbucks really
serving the best cup of coffee?
Maybe not.
I mean, I like a Caramel Macchiato myself.
But is American Express
really the best return
rate on a credit card?
Hmm, probably not.
But it's the story they manage to tell.
And I think that the more
that we think about that,
the more that we.
Sometimes we see commercials,
and we see stuff and we
just go, it's a turn off.
But somehow, those people
that manage to tell a story,
manage to even temporarily
move us in a certain way,
that we remember.
We don't feel like we're being sold,
we feel like we're being told something
that we can connect to.
So I've always been
driven by that very idea,
that very notion.
- Can we help us appreciate
this early experience,
these lean years, these
very difficult years
leading up to the ultimate prize.
- There is no prize, out there.
The only prize is this one,
and what you feel, and what
you want to accomplish.
And if you can, as you start out,
these what could be lean
years or could be fat years.
I feel that I very often
watch a lot of young people
sort of meander around without any idea
about why they're doing
what they're doing.
I mean, to want and to be ambitious,
and to want to be
successful, is not enough.
That's just desire.
To know what you want,
to understand why you're doing it,
to dedicate every breath
in your body to achieve.
If you feel you have something to give,
if you feel that your particular talent
is worth developing, is worth caring for,
then there's nothing you can' achieve.
And I think that when I
was beginning as an actor,
I was fortunate to have gone to Julliard,
when I did go study drama,
with a great number of
actors and actresses
who were going on to become
very well known, very quickly.
And I wasn't.
I think the sort of greatest lesson
I came out of about that,
was that comparing
yourself to other people
is a real mistake.
I mean my struggle
wasn't any worse or less,
or whatever than anyone else's.
It was just mine.
I think the audition
process is no different
than going for a meeting
as a cinematographer,
if you want to be in any of the
disciplines of this industry.
Very often, the thing
that actors tend to do,
is I think they tend to
focus on the wrong thing.
So if I were to say to you,
what do you think the
purpose of an audition is,
what would your answer be?
What's the purpose of an audition?
- [Audience Member] To live
truthfully in the moment>
- To live truthfully in
the moment, very nice.
Most people would say to
get the (expletive) job.
(laughing)
Alright.
That is a very, very, very
dangerous place to start,
to want to get the job.
Now, look, let's face facts.
If you get the job, how great.
That's (expletive) great,
it's icing on the cake;
it's fantastic.
But I believe that if actors
were better willing to adopt a philosophy
that it is an opportunity
to walk into a room,
and to begin a relationship
that may not pay off
with that particular job.
Sometimes actors are so nervous,
and they want that job so much
or they can't pay their (expletive) rent.
They got to get that (expletive) job.
I got to get that (expletive) job.
Hi, hi, hi.
Well we see that.
You know, the director sees that.
So the problem with that is
that you're not being yourself.
You can't be truthful in the moment
when you're focus is on the result
instead of what, on
that day at that moment,
is the beginning of a process.
Can I work with this actor,
the director's thinking.
Does this actor pay attention?
Do they listen?
And when I give them direction,
do they actually change anything?
Do they take direction?
Go that way.
And if you can stand in a room and say,
I may be raw, I may be undeveloped,
I may have no experience,
but I trust myself enough,
and I believe in myself
enough on this day,
that I want to introduce
myself to this director,
casting director, producer, assistant,
and by the way, be really
nice to the assistants.
Because no one behind that
table is any different than you.
Everyone behind that table is
just as ambitious as you are.
That director wants to
be doing better things.
That casting director
wants to be a director.
That assistant wants to
be the casting director.
Everybody wants to be
somewhere else in 10 years,
just like you do.
So we're all in the same boat.
And it's sometimes hard to believe this.
No matter how rude they might be,
no matter how;
'cause some of them are
just; they're (expletive)
in those kinds of situations.
My point is this.
They're on your side.
Because they have to cast this thing.
And because people are fundamentally lazy,
they'd rather be home
smoking pot and watching TV.
(audience clapping)
They want you to be good.
They want you to solve their problem.
And too often, I think
people don't realize that
you have to take the long view.
The short view is I want
this job, I need this job,
I want this job.
The long view is, I have
a chance to meet someone
I may admire, someone I could work with.
But I may not be right
for this job on this day.
That has nothing to do with my talent.
It could be a thousand reasons
why you don't get a job.
But if I'm good enough,
if I stand on that stage
and I show them where my
talent is on this day,
I walk out that door, they
might look at each other and go,
"She's really good.
"She's not right for this,
but she's really good."
And the next time they do a film,
or the next time they do a play,
they'll bring you back.
And someday along that long road,
you may get that job.
But it's about relationships,
and it's about trusting
yourself in where you are.
And realizing you are good
enough for where you are
right now on that day.
And I believe in the long view.
And I also believe that audiences
have remarkable attention spans.
You know, there's always
this sort of argument.
You sometimes see it in
the way movies are cut.
Where there's a cut every three seconds,
because God forbid something
isn't happening on screen;
something isn't distracting.
But if you go back and
look at the great movies,
there's just a camera,
capturing people in a space.
That is compelling.
And I believe audiences,
actually at the end of the day,
they don't care about platforms.
They don't care that it's
on Netflix or on Instagram,
or a six second Vine, or a
13 hour mini-series on PBS.
They want good stories.
If we give them great content,
not just to fill the time,
but great content that are great stories,
they will watch it on
whatever platform it's on.
- But there is something
different in a story,
a complexity that's possible,
obviously with time.
And do you think that there is,
if you like, a swing back against
short, snappier, bite-size
pieces of content,
to something that is much more textured?
- No, I actually think
there's room for all of it.
And I think that that's why we're seeing
so many different kinds
of platforms emerge.
You know, people are adapting storytelling
for the platform that they're on.
And that's actually kind of exciting,
and opening up new doors.
I travel, I play a lot of tennis,
I play a lot of ping-pong,
I see a lot of friends
and make a lot of dinners.
I enjoy my life.
In fact, in the last seven
years I've carved out more time
for me than I think
ever before in my life.
I think you have to.
I think it's hugely important
to be able to balance
your life with your work.
I'm loving living life,
and I think it's just hugely important.
I'm fortunate, I don't
have a nine to five job,
but this job does require
an enormous amount of my attention,
and I live full-time in London.
And I only leave London if
I'm going to make a movie.
But even if I'm able
to carve out two hours
in the middle of the
afternoon to go play tennis,
or go to a gallery or take a walk,
that's hugely valuable.
Even a two-day weekend can
feel like a five-day holiday.
- [Interviewer] You've worked
with unbelievable directors
and other actors, and on great work,
Mamas work, O'Neill.
Can you just talk about that,
at all about the collaboration
or about the --
- Well that is it.
That is the key to doing
anything, and doing it well.
Either in film or in theater.
You know it's about bringing
all the elements together.
And if you are fortunate enough
to not be driven by your own ego,
and not believe that all your
ideas are the only good ones,
and are open to suggestion
and to criticism,
that's not a good idea.
Don't play it that way.
That doesn't serve the writing.
As long as actors, and to
a large degree directors,
our job is to serve the writer.
Serve the writing.
If you serve the writing,
you will ultimately serve yourself.
I think we have gone
through a couple of decades
where actors have been spending more time
serving themselves.
And they have forgotten that
it is about the writing.
It is about finding out the world
that a writer wants to create,
and doing everything you
can to give the director
as many choices as they
possibly can have in editing.
And collaborating and being open about it,
and loving that aspect of it.
Because it's so incredible.
If you A, trust the
people that you work with,
and bring an atmosphere
of openness and humor
to the proceedings so that
everybody wants to come to work
everyday and do their best job.
So it is about collaboration.
There's lots of films that people know
that are always sort of mentioned as,
wasn't that your favorite?
I hope I haven't done it yet.
And every time I take on something,
the only thing that interests
me is what scares me.
The only thing that interests
me is what I think I can't do.
Well when you're doing a TV show,
you know everyday is a different day
in the sense that it's never the same.
And you might be shooting two scenes,
you might have one scene,
you might have five scenes.
So your level of preparation
is different every time.
Generally, I'm up early,
I exercise, I run,
I do whatever it is I'm doing
in terms of my physical life
other than playing tennis,
which I stack up during
the course of a week,
quite a lot of if I can.
And you know, get to set,
depending on your call time,
but very often it's very early.
And then you try to be there
and be alert and awake,
and alive and ready to go
every hour of the day.
And if you work 12 hours,
then you have to be alert
every one of those hours.
It's an important thing to stay focused.
- When someone has the gift,
I cannot resist.
I am told that you are so adept at it.
If our audience closes its eyes,
they will actually have the impression
that I am privileged to
interview some people
who might otherwise never
have appeared on this stage.
Our guest is Jimmy Stewart.
And Mr. Stewart, generations of actors
have admired your naturalism,
and your simplicity.
Now is that just Jimmy Stewart,
or is it Jimmy Stewart playing
a kind of Jimmy Stewart?
(laughing)
- Well now, Jimmy, I
know what you're saying.
I'm aware of what you're trying to say.
And the answer is yes.
(clapping)
- You can all testify now to the fact
that I have interviewed Jimmy Stewart.
Here I am; this is after all
a kind of interview show,
a talk show.
And Johnny, you reigned for years
as king of talk show hosts.
- Oh now we're talking.
- What was the secret of your success?
(laughing)
- You know Jimmy, I'd
love to answer you that,
but I don't work on Mondays.
(clapping)
- I understand that you have conducted
a long correspondence with Kevin Spacey,
and that he approached
you once, Ms. Hepburn.
And I would like to
know, what's that story.
Do you actually correspond?
What do you --
- He's a stalker.
(clapping)
He just won't leave me alone.
- When he writes to you,
what do you respond?
- He writes letters, and
goes on and on about himself.
And I just say, "Good for you."
(clapping)
- I would like to ask you please,
because you are a very good director,
as well as a wonderful actor Mr. Eastwood.
What is the word of advice
for our many directors
out there in our school.
(laughing)
- Well I'd say get it done by four,
so you can hit the links.
- (laughing) Mr. Gielgud,
am I on the right track.
Mr. Gielgud, American actors envy you.
Your impeccable diction,
how did you acquire it.
- Oh went to school, you know,
trained for years and years.
(clapping)
- Marlon.
(laughing)
English actors do not admire your diction.
How did you acquire it?
Could it by any chance have
been a result of your training
at the Actor's Studio?
- Listen, I didn't learn twiddly
twat at the Actor's Studio.
(cheering)
(laughing) And frankly,
I'm just sick and tired
of all you cats just
living off my name forever.
So leave me alone, and bring
me the Doritos would you?
(clapping)
- Mr. Walken, you are.
(cheering)
You are, despite what was just said,
a distinguished member
of the Actor's Studio,
and this is your second
time on this stage.
Do you have a response for Marlon.
- Well you know.
He's just stoned you know.
You got to forgive him, you know.
He's crazy that way.
- I'm going to call on
another member of the
Actor's Studio, distinguished member
of the Actor's Studio, to respond.
Mr. Pacino.
You've already been
immortalized by Kevin Spacey
on Saturday Night Live.
We all saw that.
How did you feel about it?
Were you pleased?
- Oh funny.
(cheering)
- Didn't bother you at all?
- No.
Can I get a cappuccino?
- I know that like so many of our students
who remember your evening
here on this stage with us.
Kevin Spacey often
looks to you Jack Lemmon
for professional wisdom.
What is your final word tonight?
What is your advice to our youngsters?
- I wish to hell he'd stop calling me,
and leave me the (expletive) alone.
(jet engine)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Dante Deluca asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you;
what change are you going to make
as a result of watching this video?
Leave it in the comments and
I will join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Anna Weber from
SuccessfullyPublished.com.
Anna, thank you so much
for buying my book.
It really means a lot to me.
For those of you who want
a chance at a (mumbles)
and some bonuses in a a future video,
make sure to pick up a copy of the book,
and email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you soon.
(jet engine)
- I can tell you the moment
I did the very first thing
in drama class where we had
to do a pantomime to music.
And I created a western scene
where I was riding a horse,
I had a six gun,
and it was to the music
from Dueling Banjos.
So the horse got faster
and faster as I went.
And everybody applauded and laughed.
And I was like, well
that's a sound I like.
And then the drama teacher there,
who was really remarkable,
and a great mentor,
then led me toward a workshop,
that was being run by one of my idols,
which was Jack Lemmon.
I mean his work in Some Like
It Hot, or the Apartment,
The Odd Couple; some of the
finest work I'd ever seen.
He just did comedy and drama brilliantly.
He was a kind of every man.
So he was running this workshop
at the (mumbles) Perform
in 1974, and I got a chance to go.
And one of the things we had to do,
was we had to do scenes.
And Mr. Lemmon was going
to critique our scenes.
And so I did a scene; I was
very shy, I was very nervous.
And he came up to me after I did my scene,
he put his hand on my
shoulder and he said,
"That was a touch of terrific."
(laughing)
He said, "No, I'm not
kidding, what's your name?"
I said, "Kevin."
He said, "This young actor has been doing
"what I've been talking
about all afternoon.
"He was connected to the material.
"I'm telling you that you
should go to New York,
"and you should study to be an actor,
"because this is what you were
meant to do with you life."
And I was 13 years old.
And it is kind of extraordinary
that sometimes in life,
a teacher, a parent, an adult, mentor,
can say just the right
words to a young person,
at just the right moment,
and it can be life changing.
And it was life changing for me,
because I did go to New York,
I did study at Julliard for two years,
and then I began my career
as an actor in the theater in New york.
And then 12 years later,
after we had met in 1974,
I found out that Jack Lemmon
was coming to Broadway
to do a production of Eugene O'Neill's
Long Day's Journey in Tonight.
And I felt at 26, I was the right age
to play one of his sons.
And I particularly wanted to play the role
of the alcoholic,
Jamie Tyrone.
So I tried and tried and
tried to get an audition.
I couldn't get an audition.
I finally had to sort of sneak my way in.
And I finally got an audition
with Jonathan Miller,
who was going to direct the production,
the great British director.
And then I had to audition with Jack.
So once again, after we
had met 12 years before,
I found myself in a room with Jack Lemmon
doing a scene; or we did
like four scenes together.
And I was relentless with him.
I'd prepared for this audition,
unlike anything I'd ever prepared for.
I was toppling over his lines,
I was pushing him.
I wanted this part so bad.
And at the end of it,
Jack Lemmon once again walked up to me,
put his hand on my shoulder,
and said, "That was a touch of terrific."
He goes, "You know what,
I never thought we'd find
the right kid, but Jesus
Christ what the hell was that?"
And I won the role.
And I got to spend the
next year of my life
working on stage with my idol.
And he then became the greatest mentor
I could have hoped to have had.
A father figure.
And really somebody who,
was such an extraordinary
example of a man who had reached
absolute the heights in his profession,
but it never went to his head.
He was the sweetest man,
and we then ended up doing
three films together,
with Glen Gray, Glen Ross,
which he used to love to
call Gene Berry, Glenn Close.
It's easier to say.
And you know, there's really
not a day that goes by
where the influence he
had, the lessons he;
just by example that he taught.
I've always sort of gone through my life
feeling like if I just keep
a little twist of Lemmon
in my heart, then I'm going to be okay.
We were talking about this
outside in the hallway.
'Cause we were talking about Sean,
about how sometimes you
can love what you do,
and be good at it.
But sometimes you don't
have to love what you do,
and still be good at it.
- That's Sean and acting.
- Yeah, we were having
this discussion out there.
And right now, not everything is great.
I certainly want things; I
fight for things to be better,
and I fight to do things better in myself.
But I also feel like I've
been given so much opportunity
that even to start to whiff of
a sort of whine or complain,
as certain other people do, who I know.
Little whining hosts.
(laughing)
I feel that it's disenchanting.
- If I saw someone like
that I'd shoot 'em on sight.
- Smack 'em, right.
So I feel like the best thing
that I can do is be grateful,
and honor it, and continue to
try to do the best work I can.
And I'm fortunate that
every time someone says
oh no he's not the right guy for that,
and I'm able to go out and
prove that I can do it.